if you needed any more data to tell you
the obvious which is that anti-semitism
and antiderivative exploded publicly
under the Trump administration we now
have the data anti-semitic incidents
were at near historic high levels for a
second year in a row in 2018 and actual
assaults against Jews more than doubled
and there is actually a long history of
anti-jewish attacks being the most
prevalent religious-based attacks in the
United States what I mean by that is
that most assaults in the US are not
over someone's religion but if we look
just that religiously-motivated
assaults Jews have been the top target
for a very long time and these numbers
have exploded according to the
anti-defamation league's record report
of anti-semitic incidents there were
1879 attacks against Jews and Jewish
institutions last year the data goes
back to the 70s and this was the third
highest year on record now these are not
all criminal actions it can include sub
criminal stuff but it also includes
criminal activity but then we get into
actual assaults there were 59 specific
people who were victims of assault on
the basis of their Judaism more than
doubling from 2017 the most common
incidents are in addition to physical
assaults anti-semitic harassment and
vandalism vandalism is a very common one
very interesting question about this is
how many of these incidents are
connected to known extremists or
anti-semites and the anti-defamation
league and their Center on extremism
have this really large database of
people that are known to them extremists
that are known to them and last year 13%
of the incidents they tracked about 250
were carried out by specific individuals
that are known to the ADL and the Center
on extremism which is the highest dating
back 15 years and this is a really
important piece because it tells us that
people
who are already on the radar of the
anti-defamation league and in many cases
are also on the radar of law enforcement
authorities are feeling emboldened
enough to go out there and carry out
actions in the real world even though
they're already sort of being paid
attention to and tracked by authorities
and groups like the anti-defamation
league sometimes we have seen
anti-semitic robocalls to people we've
seen anti-semitic flyering campaigns
where extremists will drive around areas
they believe sometimes accurately
sometimes not areas they believe have
higher Jewish populations and they'll
drop anti-semitic propaganda all over
the place we do report on the show
anti-semitic incidents that we receive
to the anti-defamation league and
sometimes to the FBI and from my
conversations with the ADL it is a
near-constant
for many Jewish media people in the era
of Trump ben shapiro
ben shapiro a right-wing conservative
who happens to be jewish a huge target
of anti-semitic harassment online look
at our youtube channel for five minutes
you'll see that that also applies here
and it would be nice to just hear some
kind of strong statement from trump
anti-semitic assaults and harassment are
up there is no place for it in the
united states period i disavow fully
anyone who's participating in it and
it's interesting that he's almost
reluctant like he gives these
mealy-mouthed statements only after huge
incidents like a synagogue shooting for
example two of which we've had in the
last six months and it's not surprising
it's a total lack of moral leadership
from trump and again it's not about is
trump personally anti-semitic it's not
about well how could trump foment
anti-semitism his daughter converted to
judaism and one of his top advisors
Jared Kushner is Jewish it's not about
that things are more nuanced things are
more complicated than that and you only
have to go to what the white
nationalists say I interviewed white
nationalist leader prominent white
nationalist Richard Spencer on the
program
a couple of years ago and he said it's
not that I expect Trump to come out and
say out with the Jews it's that we see
Trump's signaling whether it comes up
from his comments about Mexicans about
[ __ ] countries about immigration
Trump is sending a signal that he's the
closest thing to our worldview that
we've had in the White House for a very
long time in the modern era and that he
won't aggressively go after us and that
is exactly what has been borne out by
the actual real-world actions of Donald
Trump and the effects are visible so
clearly in the data if you love learning
new things you probably want to check
this out the david pakman show today is
sponsored by Skillshare and we're giving
you two entire months of free access to
Skillshare when you click the link
underneath this video Skillshare is a
vibrant online learning community
offering more than 25,000 video classes
on just about anything you can think of
get better at playing an instrument
learn to use Photoshop how to edit
videos they have classes on drawing
painting business cooking nutrition
personal productivity and I'm not even
really scratching the surface I recently
took a great class on introductory
watercolour painting I'm still not good
but I am learning and you can access the
entire library of fun easy-to-use online
courses for free for two months by using
the link underneath this video two
months of learning something that's
totally new to you something you want to
get better at something you already love
or you can get ahead in your career by
learning new skills that will help you
at your job I've gotten a ton out of it
Pat has taken some courses that he's
found really valuable and I think you'll
love it to get started for free by
clicking the link under this video